it's the decision which has sent English
rugby spinning on its axis this the most
successful team in the history of the
domestic game relegated from repeatedly
breaching the seven million pound salary
cap and now at Sky News has exclusively
obtained the documents which show
exactly how they overspend on the club's
defense Saracens were found to have
breached the salary cap by a total of
more than two million pounds over three
consecutive seasons the documents claim
that their owner Nigel Ray invested
money in companies a majority owned by
the team's England internationals
interest-free a company owned by the
brothers Billy amico Vani Poehler
received four hundred and fifty thousand
pounds
Richard wriggles Worth's company
received two hundred and twenty thousand
pounds and merito G's company received
two hundred and fifty thousand pounds
the agreement though was that all
parties would share in profits and
losses each og is named in the documents
a few times ray into directors paid one
point six million pounds pays image
rights based on a valuation by a
consultancy firm but the report says
they overspent by a hundred thousand
pounds in their effort to supplement his
normal salary outside the rules ray is
also alleged to have paid twenty percent
of England fullback Chris Ashton's 1.4
million pound home Ashton paid the money
back but Premiership Rugby said it
wasn't a commercial arrangement as
Saracens claimed the report said that
Saracens were reckless and at the very
least negligent although it did also
accept that the breaches were not
deliberate there's also no suggestion
that the players knew anything about the
salary breaches England Six Nations
squad met this week still reeling from
the news of Saracens relegation
particularly the man who was
instrumental for both teams we've not
got together I think and get something
that will love to speak about and get
out there in the open when we do I'm
gonna do meet up I think that'll be
healthy
because we're all gonna be have - we're
all gonna have to be pulling in the same
direction to the next however many weeks
and you know buckers - to get on with
them it's understood Saracens explored
the option of appealing the initial
ruling in November which led to a 5.3
million pound fine and a deduction of 35
points but they didn't feel an
additional three year retrospective
financial audit was fair
experts say the publication of this
report will provide these fans with
clarity saracens insisted they wanted
its release despite premiership would be
claiming otherwise there comes a point
in time where you have to say what we
need to see more information
we should clearly spell out to the
sporting fans the public how these
regulations operate use language is that
accessible have real clarity over it
also recognizing it to be some leeway
because there can't be interpretation
when it comes to these type of
mechanisms privately Saracens feel that
this judgment doesn't reflect their
position accurately so far there has
been very little sympathy for the club
and that is unlikely to change Martha
Kellner Sky News